- Hi everyone, Sal Khan here.
Welcome to our Daily Homeroom live stream.
As I always explained,
this is a way for us to
stay together connected
in this time of school closures.
Khan Academy, we're not for profit,
with a mission of providing a free
world-class education for anyone anywhere.
And we could never foreseen the situation
that we're now founding ourselves in,
but over the last roughly decade,
we've been building resources
that we think can really help you
as a student, a parent, a teacher,
keeps students learning
over this a very unfortunate
situation we are going through.
I will remind everyone, before we get
into the mid of today's session,
we are not for profit,
we exist because of
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
We were running at a deficit,
even before this whole Covid crisis hit,
and now our traffic is almost three times
what it typically is.
I do wanna give a special thank you
for all of you who've donated over
the last several weeks,
and especially several
of these corporations you see here.
Bank of America really
stepped up 31st weekend
where they saw that we had a need,
Google.org, AT&T, Novartis.
This is helping a lot,
but we need more help.
We are continuing to run
at an increasing deficit.
I also wanna give a special
thanks to my wife (murmurs)
this is my first Covid haircut (laughs)
I got over the weekend in our backyard.
I think she's got some skills,
obviously I'm biased.
So today we're gonna have a fun session,
I'm gonna bring on two of my team members,
Meaghan and Jeremy,
who are former teachers
who have been leading the Webinars
that we keep talking about,
over on these live streams.
And the collectively what we're gonna do,
on Friday we had a fun ask me anything,
where people were asking
literally anything,
And now I'm joined by Meaghan and Jeremy,
and you can ask us anything.
And obviously Meaghan
and Jeremy are expert at,
how does Khan Academy work in a classroom?
They're the ones running the webinars
and they can talk more about,
some of the webinars are about to run,
common questions they've seen,
but also ask us anything about anything.
So Meaghan, Jeremy, thanks for joining us.
Maybe a good place to start,
Meaghan, I'll start with you.
Tell us a little bit about
these webinars you're running
and what types of things
you're trying to get across.
- Sure, thanks Sal.
We are running webinars for teachers
who are transitioning from being
in the classroom everyday
with their students
to teaching and learning remotely.
And we've covered everything from,
how to set up your Khan Academy account
to best practices, to even having teachers
who are really exceptional ambassadors,
who are sharing their best practices
for different students in different areas.
So it could be math,
could be English language learners,
could be science.
And so we're having both our team share
some of the things that
we know work really well,
along with teachers around the country
sharing their best ideas,
to really form a community of teaching
and learning remotely.
And we have two webinars
coming up this week.
One for best practices
for supporting students
who are special education,
and one for best practices for supporting
English language learners.
And those are on Wednesday
and Friday respectively.
- That's super useful.
And Jeremy, what would you say
that you and Meaghan are seeing as some
of the main, I guess pain points
that parents and teachers are facing,
and what they are finding value in
from these webinars?
- It's a great question.
And we definitely live
in webinar mode nowadays,
so thanks to everyone
who's been joining us over
the last couple of weeks, as we move
into this new sort of world order.
That being said,
I think what we're hearing, especially
from educators as well as parents,
is the hunger for specificity.
We're now a month into this thing
and this seems to be the sort of the way
the world's gonna work,
at least for the next several weeks.
How do we make the most of this time?
How do we serve our students
and our children the best way possible?
And so what we've been
hearing from teachers is,
how do I do that at the elementary level
versus the high school level?
How do I do that in my science class
versus my ELA class?
And so for the last several weeks,
we've been having ambassadors
share their specialty,
in each of those different areas
with educators across the country
and around the world.
And next week is no different.
And we wanna make sure that,
whether you serve students
in special education,
or English language learners,
you're getting everything you need
to serve those students successfully.
- And what advice...
Meaghan I ask you first,
what advice do you have
for teachers who are...
You know, they didn't get a lot of notice,
that they're now trying to figure out
how to transition their class
and teach virtually over
Skype, Zoom, whatever.
Meaghan, what's your top tip or top tips?
- I think you're really hitting
the nail on the head Sals,
that we're seeing from a
lot of teachers and parents,
and I've observed students as well,
that feeling of being overwhelmed,
a lot is hitting everyone all at once,
and now that we're thinking about this
as being more of a longterm situation.
I think one thing that I
would share right now is that,
the focus immediately had been,
how do I use technology with my students?
But really to take a step back and think
about taking those classroom norms
to use in the brick and mortar classroom,
and how you can transition that,
and use your students
as part of a community
building process of,
what are the norms we want for our class?
What are the norms we're going to use
when we use a video conferencing tool,
like zoom or Google Hangouts?
What are the things that we're gonna set
into the classroom norms for
communicating with each other.
So focusing on building that community
with your students and setting norms and
opportunities for communication first,
and then using those
tools, like Khan Academy,
to support those norms and best practices,
as opposed to putting
just the technology first.
- And Jeremy, taking the other
side on the parents side,
what advice would you have for parents?
I think many of us are in this boat.
I felt it over the last couple of weeks,
so you're feeling overwhelmed,
your kids are at home, you're
trying to work from home.
If you have young kids,
they make it difficult
for you to work from home,
at the same time you have a
list of do's from their school,
that you're trying to take pictures of it
and send it to their teacher,
what advice do you have for parents
who are trying to navigate that?
- All three of us are very
much in the same boat.
I know there are millions of other parents
out there who are asking themselves
the same question right now.
My own kids are causing up a
storm over in the next room,
so I appreciate their indulgence.
That being said,
I would come back to this idea,
from my early days as
a teacher in training,
which is about getting quick wins.
So I know that as a
parent or as an educator,
you want to come in and
you wanna be a master
of the situation, an awesome
parent, an incredible teacher.
But it's tough to do when everything
is changing all around you.
And so what I've been looking
to do with my own kids,
is find one moment in a day,
when we have a really
special moment of connection.
Maybe it's not transcendent learning,
maybe it's not massive educational gains,
which is a moment we have
maybe a game of 20 questions,
or would you rather do this?
Or would you rather do that
around the dinner table?
Where we feel like a
family in that moment,
and not just the family and crisis.
And so, I think if you can just pull out
that one moment a day,
really seize upon that
and be grateful for that,
that becomes the building
block for a routine,
and a family tradition
that you can celebrate
even beyond this crisis.
- I really liked that.
One thing that I've started,
obviously there's a certain irony coming
from me or from us,
but what I've really enjoyed is that,
I have one of those
little tablet whiteboards
with a whiteboard marker,
and I've just been writing a problem
of the day for my two youngest.
My oldest who's 11, he
kinda is doing his thing
and he's pretty productive,
and, and my middle one is okay.
But just writing that problem down
and we sit next to each
other on the couch,
it takes 10 minutes,
but at least I'm like,
"Okay, they're doing
something kind of academic."
And then from there you get that win
and then you can start layering on,
"Hey, if we can do 20
minutes of Khan Academy,
on the math side, if we
can just read together.
I'm a big fan of these Bob books,
these early learner reading things
that I do with my five-year-old.
That gets you your wins,
and then we've published
things like these schedules,
that you can layer on over time.
And actually a to do for us,
I think is to maybe....
"cause we, these schedules could show
how you can use Khan Academy
for fairly full school day,
including breaks and
lunch and all of that,
we don't provide lunches,
but we can tell you
when they go and they could be.
But I think we also should....
We've been saying it
in these live streams,
and y'all been saying it in our webinars,
but I think even in our schedules,
we should probably say,
"Hey, even if you just do this
part, you're a superhero."
And everyone else is gravy from there.
And actually I've gotten feedback lately,
that I say the term "Everything is gravy."
And a lot of people, especially
from other countries are
not familiar with it.
And so the general idea is that,
mashed potatoes by themselves are enough
to provide the calories you need,
but they taste even better with gravy,
which you don't necessarily need.
So anyway, let's see (laughs)
We have questions coming in
from, also see, so from...
There's couple of questions
we could all take stabs at.
Some of these, from
YouTube, (murmurs) asks,
how do you help a kid that
struggles with testing?
You either don't want to take that,
I'm happy to jump into
you Meaghan, one take
- Sure, I'll take a first stab at that,
and I'm looking forward Sal and Jeremy
to your thoughts as well.
So I think for some
students it's important
to identify what it is about the testing
that might feel daunting to them,
is it the content timebox element,
is it just the concept
of, that this individual,
there's one thing I'm doing
and there's moment holds
so much weight that that's
overwhelming for them.
So I think the first step is,
is having a conversation with your child
or student and trying to identify,
what it is that feels
like a struggle for them?
Because sometimes even that conversation
takes off that first level
of what's so intimidating.
And then if you can get into more
of the details of, is it the content?
Is it the time piece?
Is it the concept of an
assessment that's so troublesome?
Once you know what that is,
then there's opportunities and resources
to kind of dig further into that,
and to work with your child or student
through that particular situation.
- Yup, Jeremy, anything to add to that?
- Yeah, I would just say
this is actually a chance
for you to really sort of focus on
the most important things and learning
which are mastering new skills,
not just trying to get a test completed.
I think that's actually a place
where Khan Academy shines.
I know with my own six year old,
when she first started doing it,
she was really frustrated
because he was still in
that mental model of, "I have to
"get 100% and I have to
do it in the first go."
When then she realized that she could
actually take the same assessment
over and over again,
depression started to wear off.
So she wasn't focused exclusively
on, "I need to, you know,
totally ACE this out of the Gates."
But instead build up
that muscle over time,
rep after rep, practice after practice
until I get to that Holy grail of mastery,
and that's what really matters.
And Khan Academy makes that possible.
- (murmurs) go ahead Meaghan.
- I was gonna say, I wonder if this is
where you were headed as well."
So I think it brings a great opportunity.
Jeremy, what you're saying is that,
we have such great growth
mindset content on Khan Academy,
and I think sometimes
that concept is so new
to students and so different
from what they're used to,
in some traditional classroom settings,
that it's a great
opportunity to even leverage
some of the gross mindset
content that we have from....
That we developed in collaboration
with Perth's at Stanford.
It's a great opportunity to use some
of that and work with your student
on building that growth mindset.
- And y'all are both
talking about a two....
Sometimes subtle things, but things
that we take very seriously
here at Khan Academy,
one is this notion of mastery learning,
which is one of the reasons
why there's test taking anxiety is,
you take a test, you got a 70 on it,
you're labeled a C or a D student
and that doesn't feel good,
while, all of us at Khan Academy,
we strongly believe in this,
is what mastery learning is all about,
is that you got, you took a test,
you get a 70% on it, not a big deal.
What Jeremy was referring to,
is you can then take a
very similar test again.
And I'm often sensitive when people try
to compare Khan Academy
to other resources,
and I look at some of these resources
and they'll just list like five questions.
And I'm like, "No, no,
no, we don't realize
"we have thousands of questions.
So that if someone doesn't
do get it the first time,
they can keep taking it
without seeing a repetition
of the same test or the same exercises.
And obviously that that takes
a pile of resources for us,
but we do it because
we so strongly believe
that, that first shot
shouldn't be your only shot
and that you should keep working
until you can get to 70%, 80%, 90%.
Maybe sometimes you can
move ahead if you need to,
but then you can go back
and remediate those gaps.
And what Meaghan is referring
to a growth mindset,
which is very popular.
It's very involved
these days in education,
which is, you'd have a
fixed mindset where you say,
"I'm either good at this or I'm not"
Or a growth mindset where you say,
"I only know how good I
am by applying myself,
"pushing myself out of my comfort zone,
"being willing to fail,
"recognizing that failure
is not a bad thing,
"that, that's actually
when I grow the most,
"if I reflect on that failure."
But a world where you
just give someone a test
and they get a 70 and
then that's the end of it,
you can't apply a growth mindset there.
Because then that's saying
you are a 70% student,
in order to actually
have a growth mindset,
you have to actually really
have mastery learning
where you get back up.
And you say, "Okay, I'm
going to try this again."
That's how it works in other things.
If you're learning piano
and you mess up the piece,
people say, "Okay, you're
70% go on to the next piece."
No, they say, "Keep working on it"
Or in a martial art or if
you're shooting free throws,
the coach doesn't say,
"Hey, you're a bad free throw shooter,
let's move on to dribbling."
They say, "No, keep
practicing those free throws."
So I think that's huge.
And Meaghan I like the
way that broke it down.
There's a lot of things
that could be happening
for a student who's having
trouble with testing.
I'll throw out another
kind of metal level thing,
which is just meditation,
which sounds fancy and sounds all new age,
but it's literally just sitting down
and trying to quiet your thoughts,
and realizing that
you're in your thoughts.
I think even for very young kids,
that can oftentimes work
'cause we can get so overwhelmed.
Because I think, especially when people
say they're bad test takers,
that's usually, that category
that you talked about, Meaghan
which is this notion of a test
that their brain starts
having circuits go that like,
"Oh my God, Oh my God,
"what if I can't answer this question?
"What if I can answer this question?"
And then it becomes a
self fulfilling prophecy.
I think if you could
kind of step yourself,
step out of those cycling of thoughts,
which sitting quietly everyday
for two minutes, three
minutes, five minutes,
20 minutes can really help.
So there's a couple of questions here.
This is a popular topic.
One is YouTube Leon and YouTube 60106
I'll ask both of them,
and please discuss the transition
from missions to masteries,
world of math was unique
and showing a more
unified view of the field,
can we create a comparable
view in the new system?
And then 60106 asks,
'Hi Sal, why have you chosen
"to remove missions from Khan Academy?
"Will you replace them
with something else?"
Well, I'll take a first step, which is,
for those of you who don't know (mumbles)
it's the part of Khan
Academy historically,
and it's still there today.
Although people are asking questions
because we are what's known
in the software field,
you know, we're deprecating it,
which means over time
it's going to go away.
Missions were a way to get recommendations
on what to do next.
Kids get practice feedback,
there's all this game mechanics,
there are things called mastery challenges
to make sure that you've mastered
the concepts and level up your mastery.
And the reason why we
are deprecating missions,
is there's another
experience on Khan Academy,
which internally we've
called our library view.
This is when a lot of y'all
have done web searches,
You fell on Khan Academy
and then just like,
"Oh, okay there's a video there,
there's an exercise there."
But what we want to do is,
Khan Academy mission should feel like,
what a good tutor would do.
It will help you, if you're cramming
for that exam tomorrow
or you're trying to figure out
how to factor quadratics
for your homework tonight,
but what a good tutor would do is,
"Hey, we're there to help you right now,
"but you and I should keep working
"together 20 minutes a day,
"so that you don't get into
this stressful situation again."
And historically, missions
were where that happens,
but it was kind of a
different part of the site
and you have to click around to find it.
And a couple of years ago we said,
"Well, what if we could merge
the best of our library view
and our missions view?
And that's what we are...
Internally, we call course
mastery on Khan Academy.
But now when you go to what used
to be the library on Khan Academy,
you'll see that it'll talk about mastery
and mastery points and it gives you
these little visuals that
talk about your mastery level,
and you can uplevel them
by working on a particular skill,
working on quizzes, unit
tests, mastery challenges.
We just introduced a couple
of months ago, course challenges.
And so we are trying to bring everything
that missions are into the course mastery.
And it's already getting quite close.
And so the plan is,
before we fully deprecate
or sunset admissions,
we will have our course mastery,
do everything that missions do,
and all the things that
the library does well,
which gives you more contacts,
it makes it easier for you to jump around,
understand why certain things
are connected to others.
When Leon asks about the world of math,
that was a mission where you essentially
to try and do all of math on Khan Academy.
And I love that notion.
I was obviously one of
the first people said,
"Hey, there should just be a place
"where you learn everything,
because it is all connected."
And so, we could...
I'm not sure if we have a course,
but it would be nice to create a course
and of course master that's world of math
and that should get you
where you need to get go.
So from YouTube, Susanna
Garcia Domingez asks,
"When school starts again,
"is it going to be business as usual
"or will we see changes?
"What the changes do
you see taking shape?"
I love to hear your
thoughts first, Meaghan.
- I think that there's a
couple of things that...
Again, this is all evolving, right?
This is a whole new world for all of us.
And I think some things
that we are expecting,
we see some are side
usually with students,
and sound, Jeremy, please feel
free to jump in here. Right?
We see some are side for students.
Now we're looking at a world
where students have had
even longer than that in
the United States especially
to look at that side
and try and fill in those
gaps from the year before.
And I think Khan Academy
has some opportunities
for teachers to leverage some of our tools
to be able to identify some of those gaps
for students to try and
get them back up to speed.
But we've seen this longer gap,
between when students left
the classroom this spring
and when they hopefully are
back in the classroom this fall.
The other thing is we are seeing
that there is some possibility
that the school year for 2021,
could be intermittent
with times in and out of the classroom.
And so I know there's a lot of people
all over the place
trying to work on pieces
to best solve this problem.
And I know that we at Khan Academy,
are thinking about additional ways
and additional resources to
support parents, teachers, and students,
with remote learning and teaching,
right now of course,
but also, how can we continue
that to make that transition,
especially if it's intermittent?
How can you try and
make that more seamless
and feel a little more
comfortable for everyone?
- Yup, Jeremy, anything to add to that?
- Yeah, so I think in addition
to sort of the challenges
that this crisis has dealt
on entire education system.
There is at least one silver
lining that I have identified,
which is so many of the teachers
who have been coming to
our webinars are saying,
"For the first time in my whole career,
"I'm finally getting
this technology stuff."
And as someone who never talked about
technology once in my entire
teacher training program,
I know that it can often feel like this
foreign world that we're entering into,
but now that we're
getting these new skills,
just like our students are
always learning new things,
we can bring new
experiences to our students.
And so I'm hopeful that,
whenever school resumes business as usual,
it's going to be business
as usual, but better,
with new technology and
new tools, new resources
to serve students even more effectively.
- Yeah, and I'll just add to that,
you know, everything
we've been talking about,
the value of personalized learning ,
where you're a teacher with
a classroom of 30 students
who are all at different levels,
all have different gaps,
You wanna do mastery learning,
but without the aid of technology,
it's very hard to do mastery learning.
You'd have to have multiple tests
that you're administered
to teach the students at different time,
and somehow try to orchestrate
kids on their own path.
But the reason...
But the need for those things,
is even going to be stronger to the point
that Meaghan just made of,
kids are gonna be out of school
for five months, six months.
Our partners at the
NWA, the not for profit
that administers the map growth,
they just released a study last week
talking about how those five months.
It's not just gonna be five
months of lost learning,
it's actually gonna be
five months of forgetting.
So it's very possible
that the median student,
if they don't get any
form of intervention,
they don't use Khan Academy,
et cetera, et cetera,
they might enter next year exactly
where they were a year ago.
So you would have a year of loss.
And so it's super important
that we leverage this time,
not just the remaining
time in the school year,
but the summer to keep learning.
And then when we go back to school,
the reality is, some kids
would have kept learning
and other kids for many reasons,
might not have kept learning.
So they're gonna have
even a wider variation.
And so I think it's going
to be even more imperative.
And it's what Meaghan and
Jeremy were talking about,
that when people come back,
we hope that they can leverage us
to understand where their kids are
and then allow more time than normal.
If I were to theorize,
I think we have talked to some districts
that are thinking about starting the
school year a little bit early,
I think especially in something like math,
although I think reading as well,
but especially math where,
once you have those gaps,
it can be very debilitating
to build on top of them.
It might make sense for everybody
to have a double block or
something for a month or two,
so they can really remediate and catch up.
And if you do have that type of time,
that's where our resources,
like Khan Academy could
be really valuable.
Like, I could imagine
a month of really deep,
everyone starts at...
We had Tim Vanderburgh and I know
Jeremy did a webinar with him as well,
amazing teacher in Hisperia in California
who has all of his sixth graders start
at kindergarten level,
and Khan Academy, if they know it,
they're able to accelerate ahead.
If they don't, well they need
that to fill in those gaps.
Within a week or two,
they're all operating,
closer and closer to their grade level.
And I think there's concepts like that,
that we could do throughout
the country or the world
to help make sure that
everyone has their gaps.
And if there's another silver lining
to what Jeremy at it is,
I think this is the first time
that people are gonna
take summer seriously,
as a time to learn.
And I think people are going to realize
that the variation is so
large to this back to school,
that I think more school
districts and schools will say,
"Okay, we've got to take up
this whatever this month,
to reduce this variance."
So let everyone fill in their gaps.
And that was always an issue,
but the issue is so big now
that you can't ignore it.
So let's see.
There's a whole class of questions here.
YouTube Nikila go vendor asks,
are there suggestions
you have for teachers
who are teaching children
remotely without wifi?
Then boy TJR asks,
the app is amazing,
but if you don't have good
wifi or no wifi at all.
And then Zachary Meadows is asking,
how could we help kids without internet?
I'd love your all's thoughts.
I'm once again happy to
give my 2 cents, Meaghan?
- Sure, from a Khan Academy standpoint,
a lot of our system is highly
dependent on consistent
internet access and device access,
which we know is a challenge
for many students all over the globe.
And so, there is one thing
that I can recommend here is that,
our friends at Learning Equality,
have developed a system where,
if you have internet access,
even for a small amount of time,
you can download some of
the aspects of Khan Academy
and use those offline.
So if your students have access,
even to a limited amount of internet,
even for a small window
during the day or in the week,
you can leverage that integration so
that students can still have access
to something like Khan Academy.
And I would say, even if they
don't have internet access,
one of the biggest things we keep seeing
for teachers and students and parents,
is still finding a way
to contact your students.
And I saw this really great post
from a teacher this week,
where they wrote handwritten notes
for each of their students
and even drop them off at their homes,
which we don't even think about
snail mail anymore for students.
And some of them don't even think
about that type of communication.
But what a powerful impact
that had on her students
to know that the teacher,
and she was still thinking about them,
even if she couldn't see
them face to face every day.
So I would leverage finding ways
to communicate with your students,
even if you can't see them
directly on a video call.
- Yeah, and I'll just add to that,
for teachers who are
teaching kids with out wifi.
I've seen teachers do things like,
the students do their work handwritten,
but at least use a parent's
phone to text them an image,
which I think is reasonably common.
And Khan Academy is usable
on, on a cell phone.
So I know there's still
people who might not have.....
They might be data sensitive
or not have wifi access,
but as long as a family
member has a cell phone
that has a data plan, a smartphone,
they should be able to use
us in some way shape or form.
We are hearing really good stuff coming.
I've talked to Dr. Jara from
Las Vegas, from Clark County.
They've been distributing laptops
for kids who don't have it.
I talked to Ray Daleo
and his wife Barbara,
in Connecticut, they just bought laptops.
They're incredible philanthropists
who bought laptops for, I think 40, 50,
60,000 high school
students in Connecticut.
So there are programs out there,
and so I wouldn't be surprised,
Obviously I don't know
where everyone is from,
but call your local cable company.
I think they are leaning into it now,
so I think they'd be inclined
to give you internet access at home
or open up other hotspots
that might be in the same building as you,
they might call your school district,
there might be ways to
get access to devices.
I've seen everyone's trying
to do right by folks right now,
so don't hesitate to reach out.
I think you'll be surprised
how much help you might be able to get.
The other questions.
So from Facebook, (murmurs) asks,
do you pull kids that use kinda kind of
and see what they like and don't like
about the content structure, et cetera,
and use info to make changes?
So the simple answer is, "Yes, kind of."
We do put our stuff in front of students,
we do see how it's like,
we do user research,
We do that with teachers as well,
And we get the data on what
people are finding, engaging,
what changes to the site
seem to work, what don't,
and we run efficacy studies
to understand is it really
improving their outcomes?
Um, so Bill Emma from YouTube says,
"We are not able to keep
continuous concentration
"on studies in isolation, My question is
"how can we overcome the situation?"
Need a suggestion from
Meaghan, all right Meaghan.
- Wow (murmurs), yeah, focus is hard.
And I would say student motivation
and even personal
motivation is hard, right?
I was a classroom teacher for nine years
and a big piece of my focus and
motivation definitely leveraged my
face to face time with students.
And let's not neglect the fact that face
to face time with colleagues, right?
That's really helps you focus working
as a group or motivating students.
And so I think one
piece to think about is,
maybe as a teacher or a parent,
finding opportunities to communicate
with your colleagues or friends,
finding ways to be still social
and share best practices or shares, ideas,
things that are working right.
This is a challenge for everyone,
and while it can feel really isolating,
it doesn't have to be as isolating,
still finding ways to work as a teacher
or a peer learning
community or as a parent,
even finding time to share,
like what might or might not
be working with your children.
I think that's really important.
And when it comes to student motivation,
I think that's a big piece
of helping them stay focused,
and work seeing some
really unique things coming
from teachers and writing
necessity breeds innovation.
And so we're seeing teachers find ways
of things around their house or saying,
this many of you complete the assignment
or you make this much progress,
thinking about our mastery system.
If you make it to master in this scale,
I will walk on Legos
or grow up my mustache
or do a tick talk video in my
children's Halloween costume.
So we're finding really unique ways
for teachers to still motivate students,
even when they're not face to face.
- Great ideas.
And unfortunately we have a lot of
questions continuing to come in,
and we'll have both Meaghan
and Jeremy on in the future,
but, thanks for joining us both of you,
and all of the work you
do on a daily basis,
helping teachers and
parents navigate all this.
For y'all as I say, every a live stream,
thanks for joining.
If you're in a position to do so,
please think about
donating to Khan Academy.
As I said, we were running at a deficit
even before this crisis,
and now our traffic is roughly
2.53 of what it typically is.
So we definitely need
your help and support.
Keep the questions coming,
keep the ideas coming,
because not only do we need resources,
but we want to make sure that,
how we deploy those
resources are most in service
to helping you, the student,
the parent and the teacher.
So stay safe and stay
as healthy as possible
over this crisis, and thanks for joining.
It's as a fun way for all of us
to stay connected with each other
in this time of social distancing.
I'll see you tomorrow.